bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat on est
ensemble du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
pour donner du sens à l'actualité pour
vous proposer des clés de compréhension
des crises que nous traversons et voici
le sommaire de ce 24 octobre
Emmanuel Macron en Israël il veut que la
coalition internationale contre daesh
puisse aussi lutter contre entre le
Hamas et l'annonce la plus forte d'une
visite où le président français a
également plaidé pour la création d'un
État palestinien seule solution pour
garantir une paix durable les
tractations diplomatiques le sort des
otages mais aussi les dissensions entre
l'armée et le Premier ministre israélien
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder avec nos
invités dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat c'est un gros plan
sur le Qatar que je vous propose le
Qatar pays du grand écart entre ses
alliés économiques occidentaux d'un côté
les organisations terroristes qu'il
finance de l'autre une duplicité réelle
et dénoncé mais bien pratique aussi
quand il s'agit comme aujourd'hui de
parler aux uns et aux autres pour faire
libérer les
aotage le travail urgent pour libérer
chaque Américain pour libérer tous les
autres otages se poursuitent tout comme
notre travail pour assurer un passage
sûr hors de Gaza pour les Américains qui
sont piégés dans ce cas précis je tiens
à remercier le gouvernement du Qatar
pour son aide très
importante le petitir son pllar son
influence ses amitiés sulfureuses ce
sera dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord donc les moments forts de la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron en Israël avec
Flora sauvage premier objectif
d'Emmanuel Macron la libération des
otages dès son arrivée à Tel Aviv le
chef de l'État a rencontrer dans les
salons de l'aéroport les familles qui
attendent des nouvelles de leurs proches
depuis l'attaque du Hamas le 7 octobre
neuf francoisraéliens sont encore portés
disparus ou retenus en otage à Gaza nos
deux pays sont liés par le même deuil
30 ressortissants français ont été
assassinés par le Hamas et c'est pour
mon pays l'attaque terroriste la plus
meurtrè subit depuis 2016 c'est une page
noire de notre propre histoire après le
président américain le chancelier
allemand et le Premier ministre anglais
Emmanuel Macron a rencontré le président
israélien et le Premier ministre
Benjamin netanahou le chef de l'État
français a proposé à Israël que la
coalition contre l'organisation état
islamique déployée en Irak et en Syrie
luttait contre le ramas tout en appelant
à une relance des discussions avec les
Palestiniens la sécurité d'Israël ne
peut-être durable sans une relance
décisive du processus politique avec les
Palestiniens contrairement aux
dirigeants occidentau venu en Israël
avant lui Emmanuel Macron a fait le
déplacement à ramala en sjordanie pour
rencontrer Mahmoud Abbas le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne avant de se
rendre à Aman en Jordanie un choix que
questionne le sénateuroger
je ne suis pas sûr que le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne d'aujourd'hui
ou le roi de Jordanie soit comment dire
les acteurs clés notamment pour la
libération des otages selon la
vice-présidente de la Commission des
Affaires étrangères la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron était plus que nécessaire la
France a tout son rôle à jouer et moi je
suis heureuse que le président y soit
alors est-ce que c'est trop tôt trop
tard l'important c'est qu'il y soit et
que la France montre que en effet nous
allons vers une solution politique qui
va mettre fin à la mort de civils
innocents depuis le début du conflit
déclenché par l'attaque sanglante du
ramas en Israël qui a fait 1400 morts
côté israélien tsal pilon en représaille
la bande de Gaza au 220 personnes sont
toujours retenus en otage selon le Hamas
plus de 5700 Palestiniens sont morts
dont 2000 enfants depuis le début de la
guerre la visite d'Emmanuel Macron en
Israël le sort des otages le risque
d'embrasement régional beaucoup thème à
aborder avec nos invités le général
Christophe gomard bonsoir bienvenue
ancien chef du renseignement militaire
Joan DEAS bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
politiste directrice exécutive de
l'Institut de recherche et d'études
Méditerranée Moyen-Orient et vous avez
travaillé pendant 2 ans peu moins quê un
peu moins dans la bande de Gaza Antoine
Basbous bonsoir bienvenue fondateur
directeur de l'Observatoire des pays
arabes je cite votre livre le tsunami
arabe publié aux éditions faayard
Laeticia crupa bonsoir lticia
bienvenueorialiste
politique on enchaîne évidemment sur la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron Christophe
Gomar est-ce qu'elle survient à la fois
trop tard après beaucoup d'autres chefs
d'État ou ou de gouvernement occidentaux
et trop tôt pour être utile puisque
c'est ce qui souhaitait être utile alors
il sou so utile donc j'imagine que s'il
y va c'est que il pense être utile
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il a fait il a
fait des propositions en effet euh ce
que disait votre reportage est ce qui
est vrai c'est que il y a encore des
otages français ou en tous les cas
binationaux mais donc donc
franco-israélien euh derrière il y a
sans doute il veut relancer avec un
objectif plus lointin c'est la relance
du processus de paix je pense qu'il est
un peu tôt en tous les cas si on en
parle pas dès
aujourd'hui c'est on peut en parler la
paix c'est toujours important donc selon
moi il y a deux aspects il y a les
otages effectivement il y a la
proposition qui fait d'une coalition
antihamas et puis derrière il y a la
relance du processus de paix le process
de Pai c'est sans doute un peu Trô parce
que les Israéliens c'est mon point de
vue mèneront la guerre euh contre le
Hamas dans la bande de Gaza euh combien
de temps ça ça reste à déterminer ça ce
qui ne va pas être simple pour l'armée
israélienne quoi qu'il arrive Joan DEAS
Emmanuel Macron doit ensuite se rendre à
la rencontre du de Mahmoud Abbas le le
le président de l'Autorité palestinienne
ce que d'autres chefs d'État occidentaux
n'ont pas pu ou voulu faire
euh ce sera un autre moment important de
de de de se VO peut-être pour équilibrer
on a titré ce débat sur le l'exercice
d'équilibriste de cette visite
d'Emmanuel Macon équilibriste il est
complexe mais si vous me le permettez
j'aimerais qu'on qu'on s'arrête à un
moment sur le moment historique qu'on
est en train de vivre en fait on est en
train de vivre une page d'histoire qui
est en train de s'écrire sous nos
yeux ce qui a fait le Hamas le 7 octobre
est abject c'est abject c'est
inqualifiable c'est inhumain c'est c'est
une horreur absolue par contre ça ne
peut pas aucunement justifier ce qui est
en train d'être commis à l'heure
actuelle dans la bande de Gaza 2,2
millions de personnes n'ont plus de
nourriture plus d'eau plus d'électricité
ne peuvent pas fuir puisque la bande de
gaz est sous
blocus un chiffre important à l'heure
actuelle ce sont les chiffres de l'ONU
43 % donc la moitié pratiquement la
moitié des habitations de la totalité de
la bande de Gaza on soit été totalement
détruite soit partiellement détruite par
les bombardements israéliens 43 % c'est
énorme euh nous sommes face à une
situation extrêmement grave et
j'aimerais savoir ce que fait la France
par rapport à cette situation et c'est
intéressant de voir effectivement leur
positionnement la France apporté son
soutien total à à l'État d'Israël mais
euh la France est allée plus loin avec
la la proposition de la coalition euh de
réactiver la coalition contre l'État
islamique j'aimerais savoir à quel
moment on va apprendre de nos erreurs à
quel moment on va apprendre de nos
erreurs les États-Unis en même temps
dans leur discours dans le discours de
Biden réutilisent le mot qui à lui seul
est un symbole absolu de l'échec
américain au MoyenOrient evil le mal
pour qualifier le amas et la Russie il
fait référence à l'une des plus grandes
catastrophehe de politique étrangère de
la de la politique étrangère américaine
dans la région je m'arrêterai là mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on apprenne de nos
erreurs puisque ces politiques là
l'histoire l'a montré n'ont rien apporté
au contraire tous les objectifs de ces
politiques qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre après vous l'avez rappelé les
attaques terroristes les crimes ABS du
du ramas le droit international fait
respecter le droit international
humanitaire qui n'est pas respecté à
l'heure actuelle faire respecter les
principes de proportionnalité de et de
et de distinction et appeler à in cesser
le feu appeler à in cesser le feu c'est
exactement la position de la France là
vous venez d'énnoncer exactement la
position de la France que Emmanuel
Macron a posé tout de suite qu'ensuite
sa première ministre a répété donc
qu'est-ce qui ne va
pas ce qui ne va pas c'est la la la
dissonance entre cette
volonté des peuples européens des
peuples occidentaux de se poser en
modèle dans le monde de se poser en
modèle de valeur en modèle de démocratie
euh en en Phare en phare dans la nuit
c'est le le discours de Biden qu'il a
encore utilisé cette modèle et de ne pas
appliquer ce modèle de manière
universelle en fait c'est c'est c'est
inqualifiable ce qui est en train de se
passer à Gaza on a 1,4 million de
personnes qui sont déplacées inter alors
je vais vous redonner la parole juste
après Antoine basb je voudrais vous
entendre là-dessus parce que ce qui est
très compliqué euh c'est que à Gaza vous
connaissez certainement beaucoup mieux
cette zone que moi mais ce que l'on
comprend c'est l'imbrication entre le
Hamas et certainement certains des des
auteurs des des des massacres du du se
octobre et la population donc comment ça
s'attaquer au Hamas sans faire des
victimes civiles d'abord le Hamas est
dans le sous-sol dans les tunnels or ce
que nous voyons détruit sont les
habitations je n'imagine pas que le
Hamas se trouve tous ensemble dans des
immeubles de 10 étages et qu'on détruit
les 10 étages en disant en s'en prenant
au Hamas ça ce n'est pas vrai donc il y
a beaucoup de victimes civiles plus de
5000 jusqu'à ce jour euh donc il y a une
disproportion l'émotion du président de
la République elle est justifiée mais
aller au-delà pour pour faire la
comparaison avec DAEs et alqïa et appelé
à une coalition internationale je trouve
que c'est un peu exagéré dans la mesure
où les pour vous le Hamas n'a pas n'a
pas basculé n'a pas changé entre
guillemets je je c'est peut-être un peu
simple ce que je dis de catégorie après
ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre est-ce
que ça ne place pas définitivement le
ramas dans la même catégorie que l'État
islamique a des motivations idéologique
c'est un état islamique sur l'espace le
Hamas c'est une sont des revendication
nationale palestinienne le Hamas c'est
l'héritier de l'OLP de l'Autorité
palestinienne c'est l'héritier de Arafat
qui a été diabolisé pendant 30 ans avant
de signer les accords d'Oslo avec lui
donc quelque part c'est vrai que ils
sont islamistes mais ils sont en même
temps les défenseurs d'une cause
nationale palestinienne il faut tenir
compte de ça d'où la comparaison n'est
raison entre Hamas et sur l'équilibre de
de la visite du du président français
justement c'est la deuxièeme partie
c'est-à-dire que rencontrer Mahmoud
Abbas à
à c'est c'est quelque chose d'utile
d'indispensable même si Abbas ne
représente pas du tout les Palestiniens
c'est quelqu'un qui qui qui est là par
la force des choses jusqu'à ce qu'il
s'éteigne biologiquement il n'est plus
élu parce qu'il n'a pas renouvelé son
mandat il n'a plus d'autorité il est en
fait je peux le dire en toute conscience
c'est le chef des collaborateurs
d'Israël dans en 6 Jordanie et pour ça
il il a des avantages de toute
l'autorité palestinienne est devenue une
autorité
collaborationniste pendant que les les
les colons continuent à grignoter le
territoire deassis Jordanie et Mahmoud
Abbas physiquement et intellectuellement
est absent en plus Mahmoud Abbas porte
la responsabilité d'Oslo c'est lui le
père d'Oslo oslo est mort avec
l'assassinat de Rabine par un juif ultra
naationaliste qui a été défendu par
netaniaahou euh je je je revient à ce
que vous avez évoqué cette coalition
effectivement anti daesh que qui
pourrait se
mettre au service d' d'un d'un combat
contre le Hamas c'est peut-être
l'annonce la plus forte de cette visite
d'Emmanuel Macron en Israël en tout cas
de la première partie de la visite on
écoute le président français c'est
pourquoi la France est prête à ce que la
coalition internationale contre daesh
dans le cadre de laquelle nous sommes
engagés pour notre opération en Irak et
en Syrie puisse lutter aussi contre le
Hamas je propose à nos partenaires
internationaux je l'ai évoqué avec vous
ce matin que nous puissions bâtir une
coalition régionale et internationale
pour lutter contre les groupes
terroristes qui nous menacent tous de de
quel moyen parle le président Christophe
gomard quand on parle de cette coalition
internationale ou régionale ou je pense
qu'il parle de coalition internationale
parce que il veut embarquer dans cette
coalition les pays arabes et la Turquie
comme c'est le cas dans le cadre de la
lutte contre daesh l'idée elle est là
l'idée c'est d'éviter effectivement
d'avoir l'Occident contre les pays
arabes finalement et donc d'où la la
manière de ressusciter cette coalition
antida dans laquelle la France a mis des
moy y on a mis des avions de chasse on a
mis des forces spéciales euh les autres
pays aussi le renseignement est partagé
donc les informations sont partagées
entre ces pays-là pour essayer
effectivement d'éliminer un de ses
responsables militaires de façon à
éradiquer la structure parce que cette
structure c'est quand même une structure
terroriste euh ma voisine a parlé de de
d'abject oui c'est pire que ça c'est ça
a été de la barbarie sur 1400 personnes
la vraie difficulté c'est de pas oublier
ces 1400 personnes assassinées torturées
violé violenté ce qui est terrible ça a
été c'est effroyable en réalité à tel
point c'est que donc c'est contre ce
mouvementl contre ces gens-là que cette
cette coalition serait formée en toutous
les cas j'imagine que c'est ça dans
l'esprit du du président de la
République mettre des moyens en commun
et surtout embarquer les les pays arabes
et la Turquie qui sont les leaders de
cette coalition aujourd'hui ce sont les
États-Unis d'Amérique euh qui
fournissait pas mal de moyens faut il
faut reconnaître dans laquelle la France
est impliqué moi-même j'aiété impliqué à
l'époque en tant que patron des
opérations spéciales et directeur du
renseignement militaire donc oui il y a
un partage des informations mais c'est
vrai qu'il il y avait un leader ce
leader était américain mais avec tout un
tas de pays arabes qui étai qui
fournissaiit du renseignement et qui
fournissait également des moyens Joan
comment cette annonce du président
français peut être reçu justement dans
certains de ces pays
arabes mal mal parce
que la rue la rue les opinions arabes
ont ont un un ressentiment extrêmement
fort en fait contre à la fois la France
les États-Unis l'Occident parce que il y
a cette perception dans les opinions
arabes d' de de la de la prévalence du
deux poids de mesure du double standard
et quand je disais que ce qui se passait
par rapport au soutien inconditionnel
d'Emmanuel Macron à la politique
israélienne ça renforce en fait ça
renforce cette
perception que la vie de la de deun d'un
Arabe en fait ne vaut pas la la même la
même même chose que la vie d'un
Israëlien et c'est vraiment profondément
ancré dans les opinions arabes et donc
je pense que c'est important qu'on
comprenne cette perception pour pouvoir
aussi nous-même ajuster notre discours
et not d'accord AC vous pas qu'on a un
un regard totalement franco français ou
êre centr sur si on a effectivement
comme objectif de pouvoir rassembler
derrière cette cette coalition je reste
sur la visite du du président français
dans ce premier chapitre Antoine Basbous
parce que face à Benjamin netanahou il
dit il faut un il faut deux états il
faut un État palestinien pour une paix
durable c'est quand même un un message
assez fort qui fait passer là oui le
message remonte à au moins l'année 1967
h quand Israël viole cette demande quel
pays a sanctionné Israël aucun quand
Obama a essayé de dire si vous continuez
à la colonisation j'arrête les fonds de
des fonds d'aide à Israël et bien
netaniah est allé au Congrès il a fait
un discours de 47 minutes il a été
applaudi debout 48 fois pendant les 47
minutes honneur qui qu'on n'aurait pas
obtenu Obama chez lui donc de ce fait
tout le monde se couche tout le monde
parle ça veut dire ce sont que des mots
de la part du président de la du
président français jusque jusque là pas
que français jusque- là la communité
internationale et même les soutiens les
premiers soutiens les parrains de l'État
d'Israël les États-Unis n'ont rien fait
pour arrêter la colonisation et
aujourd'hui dans le gouvernement de
netaniaahou il y a des ministres
suprémacistes qui veulent coloniser la
totalité la Jordanie pousser les
Palestiniens en Jordanie et pousser les
les personens de Gaza en Égypte et du
coup ils auraient un état plus ou moins
pur entre le Jourdain et la Méditerranée
le projet est là le projet que nous
sommes en train devoir depuis un an
c'est celui-là oui mais enfin en face le
projet du Hamas c'est de c'est de
supprimer Israël donc non mais attendez
Arafat avait le même projet donner au
Hamas donner aux Palestiniens peu
importe le Hamas peut disparaître demain
mais il faut donner aux Palestiniens un
espace géographique pour vivre en paix
en harmonie avec leurs voisins
israéliens sinon ce serait quoi mais ça
je suis d'accord avec vous mais mais pas
avec le Hamas c'est plus possible
aujourd'hui pourquoi c'était pas
possible avec Arafat AR massacré des
gens comme ça je parle je parle
d'aujourd'hui on peut pas faire comme
si'était rien passé le 7 octobre pendant
mais oui mais le temps fait fera son
œuvre Arafat a tué des gens
rappelez-vous Munich les Jeux Olympiques
à Munich la diabolisation d'Arafat il y
avait une loi en Israël quiconque
parlerait même discrètement avec
l'autorité palestinen l'OLP à l'époque
et bien il était pas cible de prison
donc ce et puis béin c'était pas un
terroriste entre guillemets avant de
devenir Premier ministre Charon chamir
n'était pas Mandela n'était pas en
prison avant de devenir un chef
historique de son pays bref ce genre de
chosees de de diabolisation n'a qu'un
temps le Hamas a commis l'irréparable
c'est du la terreur pure de la barbarie
mais c'est pas avec Mahmoud Abbas que la
solution viendra je je je j'entends vos
arguments mais je pense qu'il faudra
trouver des interlocuteurs Palestiniens
qui ne seront pas estampill estampillés
à Mass parce que ça ne passera pas dans
les opinions occidentales voilà je je
sais pas je sais pas comment on en
rebrra ça en terme parce que c'est aussi
de la une guerre informationnelle et de
la communication mais il va bien falloir
trouver d'autres interlocuteurs ou les
ou les appeler autrement il y a des
Palestiniens qui portent la la le projet
national oui qui ne s'appelle pas Hamas
ou qui sont en arrière et bien ils
peuvent porter ce projet mais il y a
deux solutions ou bien un État
palestinien à côtéisraël ou bien les
Palestiniens d'or un État juif pur alors
lequel des deux projets la France la
communauté nationale veut soutenir c'est
ça la vra question je juste rajouter
quelque
choseid quel est l'option qui à l'heure
actuelle l'a privilégié sur la table
pour se débarrasser du Hamas alors je
vous interrom parce qu'on va en parler
plus tard moi j'ai ces débats ils sont
toujours chapitrés et on y reviendra et
on y reviendra sans faute je tiendrai
cette promesse parce que je voudrais
quand même bien sûr mais je voudais
garder le le le fil de de ce premier
cette première partie pour faire une
sorte de premier bilan en tout cas de
l'étape israélienne du de la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron Laeticia ce
déplacement et là c'est aussi
intéressant parce que il s'adresse ég
allement à l'opinion publique française
évidemment et alors les premières
décisions que nous avons sur ce plateau
l'illustre totalement Thomas et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être même
l'objectif principal de ce déplacement
il faut absolument pacifier la société
française cohabit les plus grandes
communautés juives et musulmanes au
monde donc certains proches de l'élyisée
disent d'ailleurs que si Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas sauté dans le premier avion venu
pour se rendre en Israël après le 7
octobre c'est parce qu'il y avait encore
la plie qui étaai euh très vive des
émeutes que les banlieux françaises ont
connu en juin et début juillet donc il
fallait absolument penser ce déplacement
et le vraiment le le l'organiser au
millimètre près pour être sûr du message
que le président va envoyer à son peuple
avec donc une volonté de ménager à la
fois les communautés musulmanes et
juives il a commencé par s'exprimer en
français en s'adressant au français
alors je vais juste finir mon édito et
après on vous donnera la parole mais
justement il a commencé à s'exprimer je
pensais que vous alliez me lancer le son
qu'on va juste écouter maintenant parce
qu'il a commencé vous avez raison
Emmanuel Macron c'était le 12 octobre il
a fait une allocution solennelle au
français
écoutez-le je sais je le disais la peur
de nos compatriotes de confession juive
que cette résurgence là-bas de la
violence antisémite soit le prétexte ici
de parole d'injure d'acte qui les
viseraiit et je mesure aussi
l'inquiétude de nos compatriotes de
confession musulmane que les les
amalgames l'emportent sur la raison nous
combattons et combattrons toujours pour
que nul sur notre sol n'est peur voilà
c'est très clair c'était un message
d'unité le mot unité c'était vraiment le
mot fort de cette allocution du
Président de la République
malheureusement elle na pas du tout
infusé dans l'opinion publique française
et on le comprend bien puisque le
lendemain le professeur Dominique
Bernard était assassiné à haras oui et
c'est aussi certainement l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles Emmanuel Macron
N pas aller beaucoup plus vite en Israël
quel sera le le message principal envoyé
aux Français à l'Élysée les les
conseillers reconnaissent vous avez
raison que il y a des perceptions des
impressions ce sont les mots que vous
avez utilisé tout à l'heure je les ai
retenus du monde arabe qui qualifierait
la France de finalement proalestinienne
de façon unilatérale proisraélienne
vousz proisraélienne pardon et justement
les manifestations et l'interdiction des
manifestations proalestiniennes en est
une illustration un peu exacerbes
tensions d'autant plus qu'elles ont été
instrumentalisé que l'interdiction ces
manifestation a été instrumentalisé par
la gauche radicale qui ne cesse
d'alimenter cette polémique ce début de
polémique dès qu'elle en a l'occasion
donc le déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron va
aussi servir à rectifier le tir en
rééérant le soutien à Israël mais aussi
le mais aussi est capital au civils
Gazaoui et au Palestiniens il faut
absolument montrer que l'opinion
publique française faut montrer à
l'opinion publique française que la
France n'est pas proisraélienne de façon
unilatérale et c'est pourquoi on en a
parlé là à l'instant la photo l'image
avec Mahmoud Abbas bien qu'il ne soit
pas selon certaines personnalités
certains experts la personnalité qui
incarne le mieux le peuple palestinien
reste qu'il àmau d'Abas pour l'instant
c'est le chef de l'Autorité
palestinienne et cette image va être
soignée et va être soigneusement montré
par Emmanuel Macron pourquoi parce qu'il
va montrer ici au camp qui est pro
palestinien qu'il parle lui au deux camp
après que les autres chefs d'État éent
été snobbés quand même par le monde
arabe ouais dernier mot de communication
politique le président va faire lui-même
le service aprèsvente en quelque sorte
de de de cette visite oui c'est le
journal Les Échos qui l'annonce alors à
son retour d'Israël le président devrait
à nouveau réitérer cet exercice
d'allocution télévisée allocution
solennelle un message aux Français pour
expliquer l'utilité on reprend ce terme
hein qu'on avait au début de notre
conversation l'utilité de ce déplacement
et bien montrer encore une fois que la
position de la France est équilibrée
entre Israël et les palestinens ou
Antoine Basbous vous disiez il a il a
commencé à parler en français le le
président Macron pourquoi ça vous marque
parce qu'il il est en Israël un pays où
la langue quasiment nationale après
l'hébreux ou avec à côté de l'hébreux
c'est l'anglais il parle à côté d'un
Premier ministre qui parle pas français
qui comprend pas le français il a
commencé par s'adresser au français en
français et puis après il a fini et là
netaniahou a compris ce qu'il disait il
a fini son discours en anglais donc
c'est une c'est il marque son intérêt
son adresse au peuple français h sur le
sort des otages maintenant je vous
propose d'entendre un témoignage deux
femmes de 79 et 85 ans ont été euh
libéré on écoute l'une d'entre elles qui
raconte son euh kidnapping par les
terroristes du
Hamas j'ai traversé
l'enfer je ne pensais pas ou je ne
savais pas que je me retrouverai dans
cette situation ils se sont déchaînés
dans notre kibut m'ont kidnappé m'ont
allongé sur une moto sur le côté et
m'ont emmené au volant à travers les
champs labouré jusqu'à kirbet
Kazar fait exploser la clôture cette
clôture électronique spéciale qui
coûtait 2 milliards et demi de dollars
et qui n'a servi à rien du
tout des hordes ont envahi nos maisons
battu des gens certains comme moi ont
été kidnappés ils n'ont fait aucune
distinction entre les vieux et les
jeunes j'accueille Mathias sur ce
plateau bonsoir Mathias pour faire un un
point sur la situation des otages
français retenu par le Hamas alors
concernant les Français prise en otage
il est difficile d'établir leur nombre
exact vendredi on parlait de SEP
potentiels otages un chiffre revu à la
hausse aujourd'hui avec neuf
ressortissants qui pourraient selon le
gouvernement être retenu par le Hamas ou
en tout cas porter disparu le seul cas
avéré jusqu'à présent est celui de la
franco-israélienne Mia Chem 21 ans
capturé lors de l'attaque du festival de
musique le 7 octobre des images de la
jeune femme ont d'ailleurs été publiées
par le Hamas c'était le 16 octobre
dernier on y voit la française avec un
bras blessé quelles sont les les marges
de manœuvre de la France alors elles
sont très limitées la France mais aussi
les États-Unis et la Grande-Bretagne
aimerait intervenir même en coulisse
mais en réalité et bien c'est bien
Israël qui a la main sur les pour parler
l'État hébreux passe par des
intermédiaires historiques du conflit on
peut citer l'influent Qatar l'Égypte
d'abdelf Fatah Al Sissi ou encore la
Turquie de Recep Tayip Erdogan enfin et
c'est la seule organisation non
gouvernement non gouvernementale
dialoguer avec le Hamas le Comité
international de la Croix-Rouge le CICR
très présent dans la région et bien il
fait le pont entre les familles des
otages et le groupe terroriste et et
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron s'est exprimé
c'est presque la la première prise de
parole sur le sort des des otages lors
de ce déplacement en Israël oui car la
France n'est pas le seul pays touché des
otages il y en aurait entre 200 et 250
selon les autorités israéliennees
civiles militaires adultes enfants
israéliens binationaux ou étrangers 22
nationalités au total des Américains des
Allemands des Argentins des Espagnols
des Portugais bref beaucoup de pays
notamment
occidentaux qui seraiit donc concerné
qui aimerait s'impliquer pour les
libérer et lors de son entrevue avec le
président israélien Isaac Herzog
Emmanuel Macron a précisé qu'il fallait
travailler ensemble à leur libération
sans distinction on
l'écoute le premier objectif que nous
devrions avoir aujourd'hui est la
libération de tous les otages sans
aucune Distin car c'est un crime
horrible que de jouer avec ses vies
enfants adultes tout le monde civil et
militair et peut-être une petite pique
aux Américains qui ont obtenu dans leur
coin la libération de deux otages après
le déplacement de Joe Biden en Israël
une libération qui représente malgré
tout une lueur d'espoir d'autant que
d'après l'armée israélienne la majorité
des otages serait toujours vivant merci
Maas Mar c'est vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure rapidement c'est le premier sans
doute le premier objectif d'Emmanuel
Macron dans dans cette visite en Israël
la libération des otages la question qui
va avec c'est de quel levier il dispose
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie vraie
question la France a de bon lien avec le
Qatar comme chacun sait c'est un pay
avec lequel on a des des liens assez
forts en réalité donc il y a cette
négociation avec le Qatar possible des
discussions plutôt que négociation et le
Qatar a des liens forts avec le Hamas et
le Qatar a des liens forts avec le Hamas
donc j'imagine que par triangulle
il y a une possibilité de de discussion
de négociation contre quoi je n'en sais
rien euh mais est-ce que ce sont des
négociations État par État ou est-ce que
parce que là on a pas donné toute la
liste c'est aussi intéressant on a été
assez européococentré là aussi il y a
beaucoup de Thaïlandais enfin il y a il
y a 22 nationalités c'est un peu toute
la planète qui est qui qui est concernée
est-ce que il y a une initiative commune
ou c'est vraiment État par État alors je
pense qu'il y a une initiative commune
mais ensuite de de fait et même pour les
Israéliens ça devient compliqué parce
que comme ce sont des binationaux voire
des nationaux euh les cpay cherchent à
discuter eux-mêmes pour essayer d'
obtenir la libération et euh Emmanuel
Macron lorsqu'il arrive dans la salle
dans la pièce dans laquelle il y avait
effectivement les familles des des enfin
des des des gens assassinés ou des gens
qui étaient a Tage il y a une femme qui
lui dit on compte sur vous on espère que
vous serez porteur de bonnes nouvelles
donc en réalité c'est vraiment ça qu'un
C nombre de gens attendent réellement
donc quels sont ces leviers j'imagine
qu'ils sont pas très nombreux euh si ce
n'est jou sur l'humanité des gens du
Hamas qui est par sans doute compliqué
mais en tous les cas ils en ont quand
même ralâché déjà quatre quatre quatre
femmes euh ils peuvent en lâcher plus
mais évidemment ils vont chercher à
obtenir je crois ils vouit chercher à
obtenir du carburant mais les Israéliens
ne veulent pas leur en donner ils
cherche à obtenir et c'est ce qu'a dit
un des leaders un ancien chef du Hamas
qui dit mais de toute façon on obtiendra
la libération de tous nos prisonniers je
crois que c'est environ 6000 prisonniers
qui sont dans les mains euh israélenes
qui sont dans les prisons israéliennes
donc est-ce que c'est ça contre ça
historiquement c'est souvent ça ça les
otages ont été utilisés comme comme une
monnaie d'échange d'ailleurs
historiquement ça ça a été plutôt un
succès pour le Hamas pour négocier à la
table des négociations la libération et
les échanges de prisonniers donc ça ça
s'est déjà produit exactement
200 non pas 2009 excusez-moi je me
trompe non c'est c'est plus récent un
peu plus an c'est an ça ouum mais c'est
plus de 1000 prisonniers du Hamas rendu
au
Hamas pour un prisonnier Isral donc
c'est la preuve que Israël fait
également très attention d'où peut-être
effectivement le temps mis avant de de
lancer une offensive contre contre la
bande de Gaza Joan DEAS effectivement on
va être dans une dans des tractations
qui sont là pour le dans une forme de
tradition effectivement du du Hamas mais
est-ce que le nombre d'otage et le
nombre de nationalités finalement c'est
peut-être un peu paradoxal ce que je ce
que je dis mais ne leur complique pas
aussi le la la tâche pour moi c'est à
double tranchant ça peut à la fois leur
compliquer la tâche parce que ça
multiplie peut-être les interlocuteurs
mais ça leur facilite également la tâche
parce que ça rajoute encore plus de
poids à l'heure actuelle les otages ça
c'est à l'heure actuelle le le dernier
peut-être levier de pression qui est que
le Hamas possède euh pour une
potentielle négociation donc
effectivement je je pense que le fait
que voilà qui a plusieurs nationalités
ça permet de multiplier les
interlocuteurs donc donc non c'est c'est
voilà c'est à double tranchant je pense
Antoine bas on va reparler on tout tout
notre second débat sera consacré au au
Qatar donc on a vraiment le temps de
ciser cette question mais je voudais
quand même vous sur la la la relation
entre la France et le Qatar c'est quand
même un interlocuteur qu'on a choisi de
privilégier dans dans la région ça peut
être un atout pour négocier une
éventuelle libération d'otage le Qatar
pèse beaucoup parce que le le QG du
Hamas international est abrité par le
Qatar et que blinken dans sa tournée
régionale est allé au Qatar parler à
l'émir alors que abdelan le ministre
iranien des Affaires étrangères s'est
rendu au Qatar et a rencontré non
seulement l'émire mais aussi les
dirigeants du Hamas donc le Hamas du
Qatar c'est le vrai Hamas la la la ligne
politique il y a un autre pays qui est
important c'est l'Égypte parce que
l'Égypte c'est le poumon matériel du
Hamas à Gaza c'est par là que les aides
arrivent les beaucoup de choses
ravitaillement service secret ainsi de
suite mais j'espère être
démenti quand le Président annonce une
coalition internationale contre le Hamas
en comparant le Hamas à DAEs et al-qïda
je suis pas sûr que le Hamas puisse
faire des cadeaux à des à l'unique pays
qui vient d'annoncer cette coalition
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas été suivi même par
les États-Unis ni ni précédé ni suivi
par aucun autre pays donc cette sur
voulezous dire qu'il a pris un risque en
faisant cette proposition même t les
aotages Français j'esè j'espère il n'y
aura pas à mon à mon sens un un danger
sur les otages français particulier mais
en revanche je suis pas sûr que cette
cette posture va aider à la négociation
de leur libération ouis alors on va se
projeter maintenant dans dans dans la
suite la perspective d'uneofensive les
risques de d'embrasement et et je
reprends le fil puisque notre
conversation avait évoqué la question
des interlocuteurs effectivement
Palestiniens et je reviens vers vous
comme promis Joan DEAS sur qui on va qui
peut-on trouver comme interlocuteur
palestinien pour une éventuelle sortie
de conflit
aujourd'hui alors la rhtorique de il n'y
a pas de partenaire de paix il n'y a pas
d'interlocuteur fiable c'est une
rhtorique qui a été utilisée pendant
très longtemps notamment par Israël pour
justifier et mettre sur le le dos des
palestinien le fait de ne de ne pas
pouvoir avoir un aboutissement des
accords de paix mais je pourrais poser
la question inversée à propos du
gouvernement
israélien si si ce sont les extrémistes
qui se retrouvent en situation de
négocier je pense pas qu'on avancera
beaucoup mieux VO ce que absolument mais
alors les partenaires à l'heure actuelle
de dialogue c'est l'autorité
palestinienne ou l'Autorité
palestinienne à l'heure actuelle elle
n'est pas représentative de la rue
palestinienne l'autorité palestinenne
elle a été créée pour
administrer l'occupation israélienne
dans les territoires de s-jordanie avec
des zones A B et C c'était un embron de
protogouvernement mis en place pour
effectivement dans une dans une logique
de sous-traitance de l'occupation
israélienne donc ça a déchargé le
l'occupant israélien de ses de ses
responsabilités de puissance occupante
au du droit international et c'était
censé être transitoire cette histoire
c'était censé durer 5 ans c'est-à-dire
que les négociations euh c'était une
mesure de gain de confiance pour ensuite
négocier euh le le toutes les questions
un peu plus compliqué les frontières euh
Jérusalem le les le droit du retour des
réfugiés 5 ans après ça fait 30 ans ça
fait 30 ans à l'heure actuelle ça fait
30 ans qu'on nous vend un mirage d'un
projet national palestinien grâce aux
accords d'Oslo c'est fini c'est-à-dire
que la rue palestinienne qui y a cru qui
a cru comme tout le monde en 93 qui a
continué d'y croire n'y croit plus n'y
croit plus et non seulement il croit
plus à ce qu'on lui a vendu comme mirage
mais elle ne croit plus en la capacité
des partis politiques palestiniens de la
représenter parce qu'elle les voit comme
des complices de ce mirage elle les voit
comme des complices de d'Israël elle les
voit comme des complices de l'occupation
donc vous avez d'un côté vous avez une
population qui est coincée à l'heure
actuelle c'est-à-dire que ils n'ont pas
élu le Hamas dans la bande de Gaza le
Hamas a été élu démocratiquement en 2006
aux élections législatives palestinennes
attention sur des élections parfaitement
régulières selon les observateurs
européens par contre il n'a pas été élu
pour diriger la bande de Gaza l'Autorité
palestinienne ça fait depuis 2005 qu'on
n pas eu d'élection pour la présidence
donc vous avez uneg le peuple
palestinien on lui a plus donner la
parole démocratiquement DEP peup
palestinien les dernières élections
qu'ils ont essayé d'organiser vous avez
eu sur l'inscription sur les listes les
listes par les par la population
palestinienne avoisiné plus de 90 % il y
a une vraie volonté de donner de de
donner sa parole de de participer de
faire quelque chose à l'heure actuelle
ils ont décidé de délaisser la politique
de faire de la politique autrement le
résurgence de la violence qu'on a vu en
6 Jordanie du de l'utilisation de la
violence comme moyen légitime d'action
et de résistance face à l'occupation
c'est le résultat de l'échec non non
seulement des Palestiniens et des
Israëliens mais de nous de la communauté
internationale de la communauté
internationale et de son
inaction c'est pour ça que la violence
revient parce que c'est le dernier moyen
qui existe en fait et cette violence
elle n'est pas encadrée par les partis
politiques palestiniens elle s'opère
dans un vide politique total mais les
mots que vous utilisez sont intéressants
parler d'occupation c'est intéressant
votre discours est intéressant quand
quand on le quand on analyse pourquoi
c'est intéressant de parler d'occupation
alors qu'il y a une occupation depuis
1967 qui est condamné par intéressant
écoutez je vais pas rentrer dans ce
débat mais on peut même parler on peut
même aller plus loin que l'occupation on
peut absolument on peut parler de
colonisation aussi si vous voulez c'est
oui de colonies bien sûr c'est le terme
qui oui mais alors internationalement
alors les colonies non la colonisation
l'occupation c'est un petit peu
différent l'occupation elle doit être
temporaire c'est même légal en fait au
du droit de la guerre par contre la
colonisation c'est c'estàd transférer
ces populations de la puissance
occupante dans le territoire de la de la
de la dans le territoire occupé ça c'est
absolument interdit par loi
internationale donc autant finalement
l'occupation on peut la justifier quand
c'est temporaire par contre la
colonisation absolument pas allez il
nous reste 7 minutes dans ce débat et il
y a encore beaucoup de thèmes don dont
je voudrais parler notamment sont nos
confrères du quotidien Le Monde qui
publie un article passionnant cette en
cet après-midi de de mardi les services
de renseignement américains qui ont
débriefé leurs alliés sur ce qu'ils
savent de l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre je vous donne les principaux
éléments et et et le premier ça ça
permet de rebondir ce que vous disiez à
l'instant Joan DEAS la branche politique
du Hamas je je mets beaucoup de
conditionnel hein aurait été tenu à
l'écart de la préparation premier
élément les terroristes auraiit été
surpris par la lenteur de réaction des
forces de sécurité israélienne deuxième
élément et puis il y a la faille du
renseignement technologique israélien et
américains les Américains se mettent
dans la boucle du de de de de cette de
cette faille Antoine Basbous sur le fait
que la branche politique de Hamas est
été tenue à l'écart de la préparation je
suis au conditionnel sont les services
de renseignement américain on peut pas
forcément leur faire confiance mais
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez euh d'abord
je ne je fais pas trop confiance au
renseignement américain surtout quand le
renseignement se met à table donc il
faut chercher pourquoi il parle en ce
moment si vite c'est peut-être pour
s'exonérer aussi et pour se dispenser de
de de regarder l'Iran en face et de
régler des comptes d'ailleurs la branche
politique du Hamas est établie au Qatar
est-ce qu'on veut protéger le Qatar en
disant que le Qatar n'était pas au
courant parce que forcément le Qatar
écoute ce qui se passe ce qui se dit
entre les dirigeants du Hamas en même
temps euh en même temps est-ce que ça
vous semble plausible je que que que la
branche politique n'a pas été informée
de cette opération terroriste je ne
crois pas tout simplement parce que
celui qui a pris la parole en premier
c'est le chef de la branche politique
établie au Qatar il est sorti à la
télévision le jour même il a annoncé il
a fait des annonces ainsi de suite et
deuxème chose euh c'est
que ils disent dans ce papier que l'Iran
n'était pas au courant oui ou euh les
les pas les termes c'est pas d'aide
extérieure du Hezbollah ou de ou de
l'Iran ou alors j'ai j'ai deux arguments
contre ça le premier c'est que en
septembre il y a eu une réunion au Liban
autour de Nasrallah avec le
chefb avec Jihad islamique et Hamas il y
a eu plusieurs visites du ministre
iranien des Affaires étrangères il y a
l'unicité des fronts décrétés par l'Iran
l'Iran a réuni des proxis autour
d'Israël et dès le premier jour le
ministreen des Affaires étrangères a
fait une tournée pour plaider pour
revendiquer en quelque sorte cette
attaque et
franfaronet dernier point les ULM les
ULM qui ont qui ont servi dans cette
attaque je ne crois pas qu'ils se soit
entraîné à Gaza sinon les Israéliens les
auraient vu ils se sont entraînés en
Iran et l'Israël n' rien vu alors
pourquoi les services secrets américains
disent ça ben justement pour exonérer
l'Iran limiter le risque d'embrasement
comment vous l'analer se dispenser de ne
pas avoir vu euh quelque chose à grand
dramification et pour ne pas devoir
rendre demander des comptes à ces
puissances
ouais h parce que au même moment euh
Christophe g c'était aujourd'hui en
cette fin d'après-midi discours de
d'Anthony blinen le secrétaire d'État
américain équivalent du ministre des
Affaires étrangères dit il met en garde
l'Iran en disant les États-Unis agiront
de manière décisive en cas d'attaque
donc alors voilà on est dans des
discours diplomatiques l'utilisation
d'un rapport de service secret on va
essayer de ne pas être naïf sur ce
plateau c'est pas vous que je vais je
vais apprendre ça quand quand quand vous
lisez ça je vous avez lu l'article du
monde avant d'entrer sur ce plateau vous
dites quoi il y a une part de
manipulation il y a une part de une
vraie part de débriefing ououi oui il y
a toujours une part euh ce que Kipling
la phase qu'on attribue à Kipling c'est
que à la guerre la principale victime
c'est la vérité euh et que ou ce que
disait Churchill c'est que la Guer la
vérité est si précieuse qu'on la cache
derrière un rempart de mensonge donc
c'est bien c'est bien ça dont il s'agit
il y a une part de vérité dans l'article
sans aucun doute sur le renseignement
électronique qui a étit sans doute ou
technique trop puissant par rapport à
hum sans aucun doute ça c'est vrai ce
qui fait qu'on est un peu submergé de de
d'éléments et la difficulté de r
technique rement technique c'est quoi
c'est de la donnée qu'on capte qu'elle
soit de la donnée image la donnée son la
donnée cyber le renseignement humain
c'est une source humaine qui vous parle
qui vous dit quelque chose ou c'est un
agent qui est infiltré chez l'adversaire
et qui vous raconte ce qu'il voit ce
qu'il entend ce qui est compliqué à
faire le renseignement humain c'est ce
qu'il y a de plus compliqué à faire dans
cet article ce qui est intéressant en
effet c'est que en disant que la branche
politique tu'est pas au courant en fait
on protège un peu le Qatar c'est en
disant bah le Qatar est pas au courant
euh vrai faux ni vous ni moi n sa rien
si ce n'est que effectivement Mohamed
daev lui annonce tout de suite
effectivement se réjouit de cette
attaque donc je ne peux pas de
l'opportunisme ou pas c'est plus que
l'opportunistme non mais qu'il qu'il
soit opportuniste sans aucun doute euh
mais il réagit très très vite et puis il
donne presque des détails j'allais dire
dans dans dans ses premières phrases
énoncées donc oui le renseignement
américain on se souvient tous de la de
la fiole de Colin Powell à la tribu des
Nations Unies de faus fiole d'antrax qui
annoncait effectivement la fabrication
par les iraakiens de bonbes destruction
massiv qu'on a jamais trouvé et qui a
donné effectivement la possibilité aux
États-Unis d'Amérique de rentrer en
guerre contre l'Irak mais donc oui il
faut se méfier de ce que dit un service
de renseignement en général quand il le
publie même si ce que dit la Direction
du renseignement militaire l'autre jour
sur français sur le bombardement dans la
cour de l'hôpital
est vrai c'està-dire que quand on voit
ce qui s'est passé j'allais dire le
renseignement militaire na parlé n'a pas
parlé pour il a parlé sans doute sur
ordre effectivement du décideur
politique du Chef des Armées président
de la République voilà donc il y a
toujours une part de vérité il y a
toujours une part non pas forcément de
de mensonge mais en tous les cas de de
bluff de bluff de bluff oui on pourrait
dire on pourrait dire ça comme ça il a
un dernier élément je vais vous proposer
un un un un sondage qui qui est
intéressant parce que je je vous parlais
en en titre des des tensions entre
l'armée et le Premier ministre
netaniiaahou regardez ce sondage publié
en Israël qui voit la confiance des
Israéliens se renforcer pour l'armée 87
% ont confiance avec de points de plus
le gouvernement au contraire dévis 18 %
des Israéliens seulement ont confiance
dans le gouvernement - 25 points Joan
DEAS c'est je reviens à la question sur
l'avenir politique de netaniah est-ce
que parce que il y a un moment où il y
aura une commission d'enquête on est
dans une des démocratie peut-être
imparfaite en Israël mais on est dans
une démocratie il y aura une commission
d'enquête il devra rendre des
comptes est-ce que de son avenir à lui
dépend aussi l'hypothèse la capacité de
trouver une solution et de partir de
repartir dans un processus de paix alors
là comme ça j'aimerais vous dire oui
mais en fait l'histoire nous a appris de
la politique israélienne notamment de
benamin netaniaahou benam netaniaahou
euh et alors je je fais ce parallèle
pardonnez-moi mais je sais pas si vous
savez ce que c'est que les tardigrades
les tardigrades ce sont des des
créatures qui ne peuvent pas mourir
voilà euh et bien Benyamin netaniaou ne
peut presque pas mourir c'est-à-dire que
il a toujours réussi à à à à à revenir
sur le vent de la scène politique et à
se sortir de n'importe quelle situation
donc je pense qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer sa capacité à pouvoir s'en
sortir mais effectivement si on regarde
les sondages à l'heure actuelle ce que
vous ce dont vous parliez on a euh 86 %
de la population qui accuse Benyamin
netaniaahou d'être responsable de la
catastrophe du 7 octobre on a 56 % qui
exigent qu'il démissionne on a un autre
sondage qui montre qu'en cas d'élection
la coalition à l'heure actuelle au
gouvernement elle tomberait de 67 sièges
à 42 et que l'opposition grimperait de
43 à
78 la crise actuelle n'y est pas pour
rien mais euh il faut effectivement se
rappeler et recontextualiser l'état dans
lequel la société israélienne se
trouvait juste avant le 7 octobre on a
eu des manifestation absolument massive
donc il y avait une vraie contestation
parce que la population israélienne
avait avait peur que le l'aspect
démocratique de l'État d'Israël lui
échappe merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de votre livre euh Antoine
Basbous le tsunami euh arabe qui est
publié aux éditions euh fayar à très
bientôt sur sur Public Sénat